[Music]
you the people he'll be living and
working in bayberry mid Suffolk over the
course of the next 20 years and beyond
as elected members we are representing
you and your communities in taking
decisions which will affect the future
of our districts the joint local plan is
just one way in which the future of
districts will be influenced local plans
are not produced regularly they take
time and resources this important we get
this right this consultation is your
opportunity to have your say on a wide
range of topics including where you
think developments should take place
what type of homes you would like to see
where new businesses should go what role
you see your town centers having and how
you think we should be protecting and
enhancing the environment please do take
the time to look at the consultation
document visit our droppings and comment
on the issues that are important to you
because it is important we're running
the consultation over a period of almost
12 weeks to ensure that everyone has the
chance to get involved following this
first consultation we will consider all
of the comments we received before we
produce the next version of the plan for
further consultation we look forward to
engaging with you throughout the
production of the Jordan ocol plan
[Music]